Meek Mill has something to celebrate the
Philadelphia born rapper is getting a
second chance at justice I was arrested
by narcotics strike force unit and you
know a statement story black kid beat
locked up charged with 3040 charges and
when I went to court I was found guilty
for 40 of them charges end up getting
locked up in two to four years 2008
conviction on drug and gun charges has
been thrown out releasing him of his
more than a decade long probation you
know it's been a struggle like the way
for probation is designed you know you
got two sides of when people say they
hear like he violated prohibition you go
to jail but first of all my initial
crime I got found good for pointing a
firearm at three officers which we know
if I pointed a firearm at two three
officers wouldn't be done a view today
but the decision was made by a
Pennsylvania Superior Court granting him
a new trial and a new judge the rapper
took to Instagram to share the happy
news writing as of right now I'm not on
probation and I am NOT a felon anymore
today was mega my whole career on the
line and everything was gonna lie now a
lot of people stood up for me it was
exciting it was a good feeling I had
people showing that type of that meek
has been vocal about his legal troubles
even documenting them for his new Amazon
docu-series free meek this guy got like
about 19 and been on probation for 11
years I just thought it was real life
for a black kid in America
[Music]